we're hearing that Jets have dropped two
bombs near the Turkish presidential
palace in Ankara is the the latest
pictures from the city right now we
don't know whether the plume of smoke in
the background is because of a bomb
that's been dropped we are unsure about
that but and that would imply of course
that some of the military coup rebels
are still active and in charge of that
jet a senior Turkish official has told
the Reuters news agency that they've
been warned they will be shot down if
they attempt to use more military
aircraft and he also went on to say that
there is still some local resistance in
Ankara but that will end soon according
to the senior Turkish official so that's
what we know at this point in time
president Erewhon back in Istanbul
addressing his supporters but still some
trouble in ankara 42 people have been
killed in ankara during this attempted
coup most of them simply civilians and
we are hearing reports of other
fatalities in Istanbul itself